Today's show is sponsored by audible.
Get a free audiobook with a 30 day trial
membership.
Just go to audible.com,
forward slash hardcore history or text
the word hardcore history two,
five,
zero,
zero dash five,
zero zero to get started today.
It's hardcore history.
When I was designing this hardcore
history denim format,
I knew that we were going to want to do
interviews.
It's a good way for us to get out
content quickly.
That's interesting and that it involves
other people,
other voices,
people that you might want to know more
about and I knew that we would have
authors on because there's always a lot
of good people writing intriguing books
because I'm reading them.
I knew we would want to have experts on
from time to time because after all it's
a great use of the medium,
isn't it?
And I was hoping that we could get some
primary source people on from time to
time participants in the events that we
were talking about.
In other words,
you know,
I'm not a historian because historians
chronicle,
you know,
things for history and for footnotes and
stuff in books.
But maybe we could do a little bit of
that if we were interviewing people who
were participants in these sorts of
events.
Will today I have somebody that is sort
of the Trifecta of interviews for this
program cause he meets all three of
those specifications.
He's an author,
he's an expert and he's a primary source
and participant.
His name is Merrill Mcpeak.
He happens to be a four star air force
general.
He flew with the thunderbirds,
the acrobatic team for the air force.
He is a commander or a chief of staff in
the air force and did so during the
first Gulf War and he flew more than 250
combat missions in Vietnam.
Imagine that for a second.
He's also a noted author who's got a
brand new book out to add to his catalog
of books.
His new book is called roles and
missions,
which goes over his time as the 14th air
force chief of staff.
By the way,
sort of a bipartisan guy,
worked for the Bob Dole Republican
campaign,
also supported and was in the Barack
Obama administration in terms of it
military capacity.
He writes about his time in Vietnam and
his book called Hangar flying.
He's got another one called below the
zone,
another one called the Vietnam chapters.
If you like military history,
especially air force history,
Merrill,
Tony Mcpeak is somebody whose books
should be on your bookshelf.
We talked to the four star general now
who was nice enough to come and talk
with us.
By the way,
you may have recently seen him in Ken
Burns,
recent multipart documentary on the
Vietnam War as well.
Welcome to the show general mcpeak.
First of all,
let's get started by suggesting,
um,
you know,
the person we were,
we were contacting your publicist or
whatever,
uh,
was discussing the 50th year,
the Tet offensive.
And when I was thinking about how to
start this,
I thought,
you know,
I grew up in that generation where we
weren't in the war.
We were in the early eighties,
middle eighties.
We were the ones learning about the war
in college and the veterans would come
and speak in our classes.
And I remember 60 minutes did a whole
big thing on how here we were studying
the lessons of Vietnam.
And what did we learn?
And I thought now here we are decades
later and I thought I would ask you 50
years after the Tet offensive,
what do you think we learned and do you
think the things we learned,
for example,
by the 19 seventies or 19 eighties,
do you think those lessons stuck?
Well,
speaking as a professional military guy,
we learned a lot.
We learned,
for instance,
just as an air force fighter pilot,
we learned we had to hit what we were
aiming.
We've missed most of the targets.
I think our average distance of Vietnam
was like a 100 meters and that's not
good enough if you're going after a
target,
like a bridge or a vehicle,
like a tank or a truck.
So we invented precision guided
munitions and you've seen the results
that we learned.
We had to be able to operate at night
and we now or nobody wants to fight us
at night nowadays.
They don't want to find the daytime
either,
but we,
we re really dominate knife fighting.
Now we've learned that we had to be
invisible on radar.
So in invented aircraft.
So,
I mean,
from the standpoint of the professional
military,
we learned a lot and we improved a lot
because the war lasted so long.
Tenure for all of us got to go there at
least once.
We all saw what needed to be fixed and
we fixed it.
Now,
if you now ask a what did we learn
politically or socially,
I think that the,
by and large,
the lessons were not learned at all.
Or if they were,
they were forgotten.
Uh,
we repeat the same mistakes,
you know,
a war after war,
it seems to me.
So,
uh,
technically we learned a lot,
but big picture wise,
I think we,
we missed the boat,
you know,
I'm thinking about the concept in
business of like institutional memory,
right?
The idea is that,
you know,
you have,
you have the,
uh,
the,
the fact that the people can come and go
in a large corporation,
but theoretically when new people come
in,
they're trained with the lessons learned
by the previous generation.
I'm thinking about institutional memory
in the military.
So if you guys get a guy like William
Westmoreland who was a second world war
veteran,
knows how to fight,
that kind of war,
has to deal with this counterinsurgency
situation in Vietnam,
theoretically learns what he's going to
learn there.
But then Westmoreland retires the people
who were right below him retire.
It is,
is,
is institutional memory in the military
sphere.
A little like something like a Bush in
front of your yard that you have to keep
cut back because every generation comes
up,
we have to relearn some of those same
things.
Is there,
you know,
when you read like the Peloponnesian war
and the stuff from ancient Athens,
there's the hubris element.
Is Hubris something that,
that a good punch in the nose can,
can teach you permanently?
Or do you need to be reminded every now
and then?
I mean,
I look at the dominance we have right
now on the battlefield and I worry that
if we got into a major conflict right
now,
we don't have anyone in the institutions
at the higher levels now that have
fought,
for example,
in a real war against another first
world military.
Um,
would they almost have to do like the
reverse of what Westmoreland had to do,
where he had to learn to go from a world
war mentality to a counterinsurgency
mentality mentality if we ever had to
fight China in some islands off,
you know,
in the east China Sea,
is that relearning a kind of warfare
that westmoreland understood.
But we haven't done in so long we don't
know how to do anymore.
I'm sorry,
that's a really long question.
Yeah.
But it's a wonderful question because
this,
we're a practice to fight the last war.
I think that's even giving too much
credit.
Look a your question is our military
organizations learning organizations
that can benefit through experience.
I think they are,
but remember we fought Vietnam with a,
a draft force conscripted army,
and it was only after that that Nixon
was really forced to abandon the draft
and to create the all volunteer force.
The all volunteer force is that
different kind of army from the army.
And,
uh,
I think it's probably true that a
professional force can be a learning
organization,
whereas buying large citizen based,
uh,
army,
are not because they're constantly
taking in new guys or short term of
service and they have to train them from
the beginning every six months and,
but,
uh,
but look,
it's a good question.
It's a profound question.
It goes back to the Peloponnesian wars
or before that,
as you say,
and I'm not sure you know,
that I have a total totally good answer
to it.
I know that the army coming out of
Vietnam was not happy with its
performance.
Uh,
Westmoreland Westmoreland's failures in
particular,
uh,
and guys like Norm Schwarzkopf and Colin
Powell set about rebuilding the culture
of the army and the army we have today,
I think it's considerably better than
the one we had in Vietnam,
which was guilty of fragging,
its own officers and senior NCO and drug
abuse and other forms of,
of disciplined on the front lines.
I don't think you see that kind of army
anymore.
So you'd have to say,
I think that that we did learn from that
experience.
For me,
the larger lessons.
So are the policy level less than
political lessons and there I've seen no
evidence that we've learned very much.
I am there.
I see that this ancient Greek a problem,
a few breaths to still around,
you know,
in spades
and again,
this may just be one person.
I'm shooting an Arrow and painting a
bullseye around it afterwards.
But it,
it seems to me that there's always this
wonderful out that people who want to do
something like I want to invade Russia
and I'm the,
I'm the Nazi.
Often someone comes up to me and says,
well,
you know,
that didn't work out very well for
Charles.
The twelfth didn't work out very well
for Napoleon,
but I want to invade Russia.
So I say yes,
but they didn't have the offer and they
didn't have the off.
Therefore those historical lessons from
the past are not applicable and I feel
like there's a human tendency to do
that.
Even now,
for example,
to say if our military today went and
rethought the Vietnam War in the 21st
century,
we could do that and we could win
because of all this stuff we have that
we didn't have back then.
In other words,
we can go into Afghanistan and it won't
be the graveyard of empires because they
didn't have smart bombs in those old
days.
Um,
do you think that there's any validity
to that way of thinking?
Is that a little bit of a,
of a human nature sort of thing?
Or is there something you can do
institutionally that says,
listen,
this is how human beings behave.
So let's insulate ourselves from that
typical human tendency.
Does that make sense?
There is an element of a Shakespearean
tragedy,
man is a creature,
right?
And so,
uh,
you see these foibles pop up time.
And again,
let me,
I will say this,
that I think the professional military,
especially at the senior level,
uh,
are reluctant fighters a fish.
That's been my experience.
Now I,
you know,
I didn't know George Patton,
but by and large from my experience in
the JCS and senior Washington levels,
there's nobody looking for a fight.
They're,
uh,
their advice uniformly has been slow
down.
You know,
it really didn't work for Napoleon.
So,
uh,
it's on the civilian side,
in case of the Middle East problems that
we're having still today,
the neo-cons know the guys who had never
worn a uniform,
a dick.
Cheney had,
uh,
seven,
excuses for not going to Vietnam and the
people around him in those levels.
We're anxious to go back and do Iraq
again.
You don't have to really get Saddam.
We're saying this time that wasn't
military,
that was a political people.
And so the Hubris that I have seen has
been wearing the dark blue suits not to
uniforms.
Interesting.
I had met General Mattis wants,
and he had basically said something
similar.
He was very cognizant of the limitations
of military power when I was talking to
him.
So then let me ask you this then.
It seems to me that there's an
institutional bias in this country and
it's a human thing.
It's,
I don't blame anyone against,
let's call it the can't do general as
opposed to the can do general.
So let's say we're talking about the
50th anniversary of Ted and we're
talking about Vietnam and Johnson or
Nixon brings in a couple of military
advisors and out of the five of them,
four of them say,
of course we can win this war.
Let me tell you how to do it,
put me in charge and I'll do it.
And one guy says,
no,
you're not going to win this.
It's over.
Let's figure out a way to get out of
here with honor.
Isn't there a natural tendency to say,
listen,
the can't do guy,
I'm not going to go with that.
I'm going to go with somebody who tells
me he can get it done.
And isn't there a sense in the military
of,
I don't want to be the guy that says we
can't do this.
I don't want to be thought of as the guy
who says this is unwinnable.
Of course you put me in charge and I'll
get it done.
Um,
seems to me that it's,
it's tough for someone to stand up in
that sort of situation and say,
let's not do this.
We wouldn't be successful.
It wouldn't be prudent.
Does that have any,
when you're talking about the
institutional failures with the people
who wear suits,
is that a problem that they're going to
run into?
You know,
Dan,
again,
you put a very deep question,
but let me just say that isn't the way I
have seen the problem formulated during
my time in Washington now.
I'm sure this changes as the cast of
characters changes in Washington,
but typically the president doesn't ask
advice of five guys and uh,
you know,
for him.
So yeah,
I can do it.
One Says No.
What the president says is,
Hey,
we've got a problem here.
What are my options?
So he's not looking for a yes,
no answer.
It's not a binary problem.
What he's looking for is,
you know,
Gimme a half a dozen things I might do
here.
Tell me the pros and cons of each thing.
Let me make a decision.
So,
uh,
in that case,
it's,
if you're opposed to taking a military
action,
you just put it in the conscious.
So here's the deal,
we're going to lose friends around the
world,
we're going to lose international
standing,
a trade's going to dry up or whatever.
You can put an econ and you want,
but,
but the,
the proper approach from the military
advisors is to say,
okay,
if you want to do this,
here's how you,
here are a set of options and the,
and the and the,
uh,
and the pluses and minuses to go with
them and then it's up to you.
So it's a little different formulation
than the one you put.
Okay?
So if you're the military advisor and
you've been in the role of been chief of
staff before you,
you've been the air force,
uh,
a four star general here.
I mean,
if somebody comes to you,
the presence that I need your advice on
this and he says something to the effect
of,
um,
Oh God,
I'm losing my train of thought.
General.
I'm getting old now.
Fifty two,
just a little low.
I know I'm getting their aging quickly.
Okay,
here's what I wanted to get with that.
So,
so,
so the old line about the Vietnam War
was the political nature of the
president,
for example,
operating as a person who's picking
tactical targets for aircraft to bomb.
And yet the old argument that we learned
back in,
in military history class for why that
might have been necessary was the
president's got to worry about,
you know,
Soviet involvement,
the threats of nuclear war,
you know,
other things happening,
including maybe funding a,
the very people you're fighting at a
higher level to compensate.
Whereas the guys on the ground,
the military leaders are worried about,
okay,
how do I get victory in this theater of
operations?
What is the proper balance in your mind
between a president who's got to worry
about the grand strategy across the
world and the general who's got to say,
listen,
if you just take your hands off of me,
I'll win this theater for you.
Um,
how do you see the balance of the
general says,
you know,
general mcpeak,
if the President says,
General Mcpeak help me out here,
what do you tell them to do?
Visa VI allowing generals to have a free
hand versus a Lyndon Johnson who's maybe
more worried about the Soviet Union than
he is about making sure no more resupply
ships get into Haiphong harbor.
Yeah.
Well,
this is a problem which is at the heart
of limited warfare.
Uh,
if for instance,
you asked Curt Lemay
representative
a bomb went back into the stone age.
In fact,
he did say that and we could have won
had we knew Tannoy the war would've been
over right.
So the war was always winnable.
It was just a question of what means,
how limited are the means you want to
use you.
So you go to the presenter,
okay.
I'm assuming you don't want to use
nuclear weapons.
I mean,
we have an instance case right now
that's very relevant.
North Korea.
So if we seek to intervene in North
Korea,
the first question we should ask
ourselves is,
is this a limited war or the means we're
going to use limited now?
And not just the message,
it will have a limited amount of time.
No.
Are you going to put a limit on the
amount of money we're going to spend?
So you have to decide all of the
boundaries of the limitations you're
going to put on warfare and then that
has to be bought by the president.
I mean you have to tell President
Johnson,
okay,
if I have to worry more about the Soviet
Union and I do a winning in quotes and
say in South Vietnam,
that's fine.
Just tell me that and that means I can't
mine Hanoi harbor and blow up some
Soviet boat.
Now are you willing to live with that?
So the president has to understand that
the nature of the war,
it's going to be limited and that means
we may or may not win.
If it's unlimited,
I know we can be north Vietnam or North
Korea anytime.
So the first question you have to ask
are,
what limitations are you going to put on
me?
So we understand all of that.
Typically today we don't talk in terms
of limited war.
We talk in terms of rules of engagement.
What rules of engagement is the
president or the secretary of defense or
the theater commander or whatever going
to impose on operations,
and we need to be eyes wide open about
that upfront.
Now inside the rules of engagement,
I would argue you ought to give the
military guy as much flexibility as
possible.
I don't want the president picking
targets in the basement of the White
House,
you know,
because he doesn't know much about
targeting a no.
He's going to pick the wrong targets.
Where are you gonna?
Tell me to attack them from the wrong
direction or it's going to tell me to
use the wrong munitions or he's gonna.
Tell me to send to few airplanes or too
many airplanes.
Those are.
Those are questions that he knows very
little about and what he needs to do is
impose rules of engagement.
Tell me what the limitations are and
leave me alone.
And then as long as I operate inside the
limitation,
she should never have no any kind of a
quibble or complaint about how I'm,
how I'm doing and what the result is.
So the consequence,
you know,
the fact is we never lost a battle in
Vietnam.
We just lost the war and uh,
so he has,
and I'm not a big fan of West Berlin,
I regard him miss rather dumb and mean
that is what he tried to do with stupid
in my opinion and not much,
not much improved when he was succeeded
by the Abrams,
although there's a big school of thought
that says Abrams was a much more
talented officer and we were on the
right track once we got rid of.
But in any case,
you know,
the point is that there are things that
politicians are expert in and there are
things that professional military or
expert in and we need to understand who,
who,
who does what here,
when you're picking targets in the
basement of the White House,
you're on the wrong track and you are
going to lose,
in my opinion,
because you got the wrong guy doing the
wrong thing
on the right track.
I think that's a key point.
So when I'm watching Ken Burns Vietnam
documentary,
one of the things that just screams at
you,
I was reminded once again at the
veterans coming into the class I was in
the 19 eighties,
was it screams at you,
is that you don't have any real way of
determining how you're doing at any
given time.
I mean the classic way that was used was
body count,
but we understand that if you don't have
body counts,
it's how you.
How do you measure progress in a way
that's helpful to the heads of the
military,
the political heads and the population
as a whole.
And we could apply this to the situation
in the Middle East for example,
right now.
I mean,
how do you gauge progress and if
progress isn't going the way you want,
do you double down on the efforts or do
you determine that?
Maybe.
I mean are we even capable of cutting
loose?
Was there ever another choice?
In Vietnam we act like we could have
just said,
listen,
we're losing the war so let's get out.
But you know,
isn't the most difficult thing in the
world to disengage from combat with an
enemy strategic level or tactical level.
So I guess what I'm asking is,
um,
how do you gauge progress whether or not
you're winning or losing,
and then do you notice if it's not in
your interest to notice that your,
for example,
not winning,
you know,
can you get.
Because in the Vietnam War you're
looking at these people that just seem
in retrospect,
they look like they know the war is
over,
but they can't say it,
they can't prove it,
they can't,
they can't operate or do anything about
it.
They seem frozen in the condition.
So there seems to me to be a real need
to be able to measure progress and then
have some sort of reaction to the data
you're getting.
Um,
can you,
can you suggest a way maybe we could do
that in the Middle East right now.
And if we decided it wasn't going well,
what do you do then?
Well,
I mean,
isn't this the crux of the issue?
Right?
Are we winning or losing?
And if we're winning or losing,
what do you do about it?
Just quickly for the answer.
But no,
there used to be a way of judging.
It was pretty easy territory.
Uh,
you want,
if,
if you prevail,
if you held the battlefield at the end
and the other guy left,
you were winning,
right?
So Churchill could be very worried about
what was going on in north Africa
because Ronald pushed all the way to
Alabama,
you know,
he was inside Egypt,
right?
For Cairo.
And the Suez Canal was threatened
because the geography told Churchill
that he was losing.
So we replaced a whoever it was with,
uh,
Montgomery,
it's not so in a linear war where armies
face each other,
you can tell who's winning by,
where the front line is and what
direction it's moving.
Or at least that's,
that's one gross approximation.
No,
if you're fighting and Gettysburg,
you're not in good shape.
Totally.
Okay.
So you got to be fighting and
Chancellorsville or someplace downtown.
Now it's not so easy anymore with a
stateless actors like Isis or,
uh,
you know,
a suicide bombers.
How can you tell if you're winning?
I mean the guys doesn't have any
territory to capture.
He doesn't have a national treasury that
you can loot.
He doesn't even really have a life worth
living otherwise you wouldn't be in the
suicide bombing does.
Right?
He doesn't care about his own life.
So in this,
in this kind of war,
how do you judge where you are?
I don't think we have already answered
to that.
You know there's there,
if we had a sort of an index of
violence,
he would say,
well the violence is down and we kind of
have that,
but in Afghanistan now we have the
Taliban bombing again inside Kabul.
Right.
And so the number,
you can plot the number of incidents on
a graph and say and just say,
well they're more incidents this month
and there were less month.
You're not doing very well.
And in fact that's what I'm doing in the
Middle East now,
sort of subjectively.
I don't know.
I don't have a chart in my office that I
keep track of this specifically,
but it seems to me I get.
I have the sense that we're not doing
very well in Afghanistan and Iraq and
uh,
you know,
I,
I don't know how to come unstuck from
it.
This is a tar baby kind of deal where
you say,
Gee,
I wish I could figure out how to get out
of here with my pride and,
you know,
a reputation and shape.
I don't see a way to do it.
Uh,
we're,
we're kind of stuck to the problem in
the Middle East and who knows how to
judge whether we're doing better or
poorer than we were.
Uh,
you know,
not to go a year ago,
five years ago,
hard to say.
It's funny you say that.
I wasn't expecting that answer because
it leads you to the next question,
which is,
if you can't figure out how you're doing
and if you really don't have any
options,
if you're totally stuck.
You know,
I remember being told a long time ago by
my stepfather who was trying to explain
to me the wide range of presidential
actions that I always assumed was
possible was a myth.
And that when you actually got into the
office,
it was really much more constrained by,
by what your predecessor left you,
a bunch of other things like,
you know,
I can't fight the Vietnam war the way I
want because the Soviet Union might get
involved.
Um,
when you look at the current,
let's call it the war on terror
situation,
I don't see.
I mean,
how do you get out of that when,
you know,
the old,
the old equation,
which is it costs these elements that
we're fighting pennies on the dollar
compared to what it costs for us to
counter them.
I mean the longterm graphing out of that
situation looks horrible.
If you know,
it's,
I,
I feel like we could be doing a
documentary with Ken Burns 150 year old
Ken Burns years from now having the same
conversation about the current situation
we're in,
in the war on terror that I just saw the
other night when I was watching the
Vietnam war documentary.
And if that's the case,
you know,
you get this feeling like Deja Vu all
over again or a train wreck that you've
seen before and that it's happening in
slow motion,
but you're finding out exactly how
limited the people in the late sixties
were in terms of their options.
Does it feel like that to you at all?
Or does it seem like a tough.
Because the context of the Cold War and
all that is so different.
Um,
how similar to you would you feel if you
were a president in office in Lyndon
Baines Johnson's chair versus,
um,
Donald Trump's chair.
Don't ask me that one.
Okay.
We can go back and see if it makes it
easier.
Key issue is how do you define factory?
Another way of saying what,
what's our purpose?
What's our goal?
If you tell me what our purpose is in
the Middle East,
I'll tell you how we're doing.
You tell me how to define victory in the
Middle East.
And I'll tell you whether we're on the
10 yard line,
the 15 yard line and 50 yard line where
we are.
But I don't recall anybody ever saying,
here's our objective,
here's,
here's how we would define victory.
And if you don't have a definition of
victory,
then you don't know when to quit or our
window retire or how to get out,
you know,
because you can't tell.
You know,
we,
we'd like to.
I mean,
George W dot Bush famously went on a
aircraft carrier instead under a sign
that said mission accomplished.
I remember that.
That was how many years ago?
So at least 15.
We're still in Iraq.
If our mission was accomplished when
George W dot Bush went on that boat and
declared victory,
what the heck are we still doing in
Iraq?
Well then you get back to your question
though about is this is everything we're
facing now,
sort of a bit of blowback.
I mean,
do we stir up a hornet's nest and we're
still dealing with individual Hornets
and it would have been better had we
left,
you know,
the Hornet and chief Saddam Hussein in
charge because at least we weren't the
ones who had pick up the pieces.
I mean,
I guess you know what,
what amateur armchair historians like
yours truly do general as you almost
certainly know as we look at these and
we try to find meaning from the past,
which is this,
this,
this horrible fool's game.
But,
but,
but I mean,
when you look at this,
you go,
I mean,
you almost get to a point where you say,
would Saddam Hussein and the Middle East
we had in 1991 be an applicable trade
that a modern politician would,
would trade today if they could get back
to that?
Yes.
In fact,
I would have traded at the time I wrote
an op Ed pieces and made speeches
against Iraq.
It drove me out of the Republican Party.
You know,
I ended up supporting Obama in 2008.
In fact,
I was the national culture of his
presidential campaign and the issue for
me was how badly a that whole thing had
been handled and putting my buddy Colin
Powell going in front of the General
Assembly and making outrageous claims
claims.
Did I?
I thought I knew.
In fact,
at the time,
we're wrong about Saddam Hussein's
having weapons of mass destruction or
the other lies that were told,
you know,
Saddam Hussein and bin Ladin,
we're good buddies.
Bologna.
There wasn't any al Qaeda in Iraq,
as long as the dom was saying was they
hated each other or that we would be
welcomed as liberator's.
You know,
people would throw bouquets of roses as
our guys going into Baghdad.
Bologna as it turned out.
So I said that it's a diamond and you
know,
a trillion dollars later and thousands
of lives later,
we're stuck with in Iraq that is much
worse than what it was when Saddam
Hussein was running it.
So,
uh,
you know,
the real issue here is what are our
purposes?
How do we define victory?
What limitations are we going to put on
our use of violence to achieve these
purposes?
These are very deep questions,
very hard questions to answer.
And,
uh,
and then frankly,
most,
most presidents need as much help as
possible to get to these answers that
they need help from,
you know,
wise and good military advisors,
which I don't think they,
they always get.
You were just talking a second ago about
Colin Powell respected military
authority,
but using that authority,
uh,
um,
as part of an effort to sell the
American people and the world on,
on a particular foreign policy move.
And it occurs to me,
you know,
one of the things that,
that watching the Ken Burns Vietnam
documentary really brings home is the
context of what a different America.
It was back in the,
when Vietnam was heating up the early 19
sixties.
I was born during the Yod rang battle.
I mean,
so 1965 when things are really heating
up with ground troops.
Um,
the government at that time was assumed
to be telling the truth by just about
everyone.
It was a black and white good and evil
world.
Um,
you know,
I always tell young people when I'm
talking to them,
I always bring up the first world war
and I talk about a generation of people
that could watch,
uh,
the,
the unit in front of them,
step out of the trenches and go over the
top and be machined gun within 10 yards
of the trench.
And then the next wave will do the same
thing.
And I said we wouldn't do that today in
the same way that much of the stuff that
in 1962 era American would've considered
a truism,
um,
would be much more skeptically by a 21st
century American.
How much did you know the,
the,
so called credibility gap over several
administrations in that era,
do you know lasting the boy who cried
wolf type damage to our government's
ability to be trusted with statements
like how the war is going or anything
else?
What did we sort of.
Did we lose our innocence?
I guess as a classic phrase from my 19
eighties,
Vietnam War,
military history class?
Well,
in particular,
the Pentagon papers,
you know,
after they were published in the New
York Times,
The Washington Post,
uh,
Americans came to understand that a
succession of administrations,
both Democrat and Republican had
systematically lied to the American
people.
And I don't think that was that our
country has ever been the same again,
the skepticism,
uh,
which that whole episode properly
aroused has been with us ever since.
And I frankly,
it is a loss of medicines for us.
And,
and if you look at our history,
we were never a great power until after
World War One.
So our,
our,
uh,
experience on the world stage was pretty
limited,
uh,
you know,
maybe 50 years of experience as a,
as a real actor in international
affairs.
And then finally we,
we woke up a bit,
we saw how that sort of thing happens.
It's not,
the government weren't cynical before.
I think the Brits were,
the British government has been cynical,
you know,
for a long time,
but Americans were truly a children of
the frontier,
uh,
you know,
with,
with a sort of a,
a Western heritage frontier parentage.
And we wanted to believe that our
government was telling the truth,
but we learned in the Pentagon papers
that that's not so.
And ever since we've been,
I think properly skeptical.
I guess the logical question is why do
you think,
you know,
I think the tendency would be to blame
some president from the opposite
political party and,
and demonize them.
But as you said,
this was a,
a multi administration effort to keep
from the people who are supposed to
understand what's going on so they can
be informed voters from really knowing
what's going on.
And it started with,
you know,
Eisenhower even,
but even to the end with Nixon and
Christmas bombings that were secret.
I mean,
what was,
I guess,
was it kept secret in your mind for,
for military reasons or was it kept
secret because the reaction of the
American people to their own policies
was what the government was worried
about.
I think it was the latter.
Really.
The government didn't.
The president didn't want to be
embarrassed.
Embarrassment is the worst possible
situation for a public figure.
And so the bombing of Cambodia,
for instance,
was a secret from the American people.
It's sure as hell wasn't secret from the
Cambodians what are the north Vietnamese
army,
which was using Cambodia for sanctuary.
They knew all about it.
So the secrecy,
there wasn't a military necessity at
all.
The enemy quite understood what was
going on.
The,
the,
the secrecy was required to keep the
American people in the dark.
And the only,
the only reason for that is the
government would have been embarrassed
to admit what was going on.
That's the worst possible reason to,
uh,
classify a,
any information is to protect,
to protect yourself from embarrassment.
But that's exactly what was going on.
Do you think that the efforts of the
media today are.
I want to compare them to the media
efforts in Vietnam,
which we're so scrutinized and yet
perhaps so influential on what went on
and I just,
I'm not even sure we're talking apples
and oranges here in the,
in the ability to compare them,
but how would you compare today's media
coverage of America's conflicts and
that,
for example,
take 19,
67,
68?
Because it was very different in 62,
but how would you,
how would you compare the media's job,
how they cover with the restrictions by
the way that we understand?
I mean they don't have the same kind of
ability to show this.
I mean the combat footage that,
it,
not to change the subject but,
but the thing that rocked me in Ken
Burns' documentary the most,
and I have no idea how he did it,
is there's segments where you'll see 35
seconds in a row of that looks like it
was shot yesterday,
high definition stuff.
And you know,
for people like me who've seen a lot of
that footage,
I couldn't figure out if it's computer
enhanced or what,
but,
but when you're looking at what the
media is able to show back then and the
difference in the coverage today,
can you compare in your mind's eye,
um,
the pros and cons of the way we did it
then and how we do it now?
Media coverage in Vietnam was by and
large positive in my opinion,
except for photo coverage.
You know,
the,
the impact of a photograph or today
video is so much more,
uh,
a pervasive or influential or stocking
know you got a photograph of a,
of a police general in Saigon shooting
or a guy in the head or a,
or a,
a very young girl running away from the
village.
It's been an avon.
Whether skin on fire these pictures,
uh,
convey a message in a way that written
journalism or broadcast journalism
cannot.
And,
and they were very negative.
I mean a Buddhist monks,
you know,
emulating themselves in the streets of
Saigon when you show that you show it on
television,
it just is merciless and the message it
can base.
And so for my money,
until Walter Cronkite,
uh,
came on CBS news and said,
hey,
we're not winning guys.
After 10,
uh,
the,
the coverage was pretty universally
supportive.
The written coverage,
but the photographic coverage underlie
just,
uh,
undermined everything that was being
said in print.
Now today it's a,
the coverage is much more visual,
much more video oriented and photo
oriented.
And so the bad news hits earlier I think
because photo,
you know,
you don't see a photograph of,
of a ribbon cutting,
so it has downtown Baghdad is liberated.
You see these awful scenes of devastated
towns that we're creating in the Middle
East.
I mean there's no getting around it.
We're,
we're in a large scale destructive mode.
They're in the Middle East and that's
what people are seeing.
They're not seeing any upside,
you know,
you can talk about upside all you want
and how well we're doing and so forth.
But what we are seeing is awful.
The consequences of combat there.
And so I think the coverage today is
much more pessimistic and skeptical and
even perhaps a cynical but because they
are showing not just telling and from
now on I expect that's a way that
coverage will be.
Because this gentleman,
you know,
our younger generation is much more
video oriented and won't read the New
York Times.
Watch it on,
you know,
on facebook.
Yeah.
Once upon a time it used to be Radio
Free Europe trying to get a little teeny
signal over the iron curtain.
Now that if we were fighting the north
Vietnamese army,
they would have a troll of people on
twitter,
you know,
giving their side of the story or
pretending to be Americans
complete with photographs.
Fake photographs.
Yes,
exactly.
You're right.
Well then let me,
let me ask you a little bit of not
really changing subjects,
but I can't have a four star general on
here without mining you a little bit for
some knowledge and wisdom myself.
I'm looking at Syria and I'm looking.
You had talked about,
you know,
in destructive mode right now,
but to have an arm chair person like me,
it looks like a terribly small theater
to have that many different forces
operating in and us hoping to keep
everything clean with no major mistakes
and whatnot.
Um,
you had talked about North Korea as
well.
Can you talk to me a little about those
two hot spots and if there's a third one
you would add to the mix of places we
need to be careful right now
is the most important and threatening
problem that we face anywhere in the
world or have faced for a long time.
I really think we're up against a,
a sort of a Cuban missile crisis,
so it's been that long since we've
really been looked down the barrel gun
drill as far as Syria goes.
Um,
it is an awfully small theater of
operations,
especially on the air side.
We're talking about aircraft like the,
uh,
[inaudible] that that's super cruise.
In other words,
there are supersonic there.
They're running around the sky at one
point seven,
one point eight bucks all the time and
that makes Syria pretty small countries
even do a one,
a two,
a 180 degree turn in,
you know,
and the Russians are,
they're sharing that airspace now.
We've so far been able to coordinate
that air activity pretty well,
even though the Russians did lose a
fighter to a circuit,
to a target or a ground fire.
So,
but the less,
you know,
we're running a head to head against
each other in a very small airspace and
it's a tribute to the professionalism of
our air force that we haven't already
shot down a few of those guys.
Uh,
but that's,
uh,
that's terribly dangerous.
We could be any day involved in a head
to head fight with Russian aircraft and
where that,
you know,
that that's got the potential to go,
to escalate,
to go anywhere.
So it's dangerous in my opinion.
It's less dangerous than the situation
in North Korea where we have apparently
a crazy guy in charge of a,
a government that is the,
does possess nuclear weapons and is
rapidly developing the capability if it
doesn't already have them to deliver
those nuclear weapons against American
cities.
Uh,
I think that's an awful situation.
I think we can't allow that to continue.
I believe we must intervene and do
something there.
Now what should we do?
Well,
I'm in favor of using all the tools in
the toolbox.
If you think diplomacy will work,
by all means,
let's do it.
If you think we can,
uh,
you know,
economic sanctions will work.
Let's impose them.
If you think the Chinese can help us or
the Russians can help us.
Well,
I all means let's involve them.
At the end of the day,
I think we've tried just about
everything here and nothing has worked
so far because what we have to do is
dismantle its nuclear capability.
We can allow,
in my opinion,
North Korea to continue to develop a
nuclear,
uh,
me threats against the American American
homeland,
property and citizens and institutions
and so forth that,
that has to be dismantled and I believe
it has to be dismantled relatively
quickly.
We don't have forever to deal with this
problem or it will get to a point where
we can't deal with it now.
I think we should deal with it with
conventional weapons and I rather than
use nuclear weapons against North Korea.
And I think we still have the capability
to do that too.
Just to help the,
you know,
them dismantled its capability.
Well,
we need to get with it pretty soon
because,
uh,
you know,
Time's running out on him.
Go back to some of the constraints maybe
that a guy like Johnson was operating
under.
What if the Chinese or Putin's
government tell us,
no,
don't do that.
Well,
I don't think.
we know that already.
First of all,
but remember the North Korean nuclear
capability is a bigger threat to
Beijing,
a bigger threat of glad of a stock and
it is to Honolulu or Chicago,
so there's every reason to believe that
they would wish to cooperate us.
If not,
then so be it.
No,
we,
we have the means to deter China and
Russia.
We've shown that already.
The question is we don't,
I think know for sure or,
or with great enough probability that we
can deter North Korea.
I mean,
I've heard it argued that this guy,
Kim Jong Gun is a rational person.
All he wants to do is hold power.
Therefore he has something to lose.
Therefore he detour trouble and I think
that's probably right.
My question is,
what if it's well,
what are the odds that he's not the
terrible?
Say there,
say it's only 10 percent,
so do we want to make it a bit?
Again,
we want to bet Chicago or New York City
that he's deterrent will when the odds
are 10 percent say that he's not the
terrible.
I don't think we want to take that bet.
And by the way,
at the overview ought to be here about
nuclear proliferation.
Where are we going to draw the line?
Is it okay for Nigeria or Honduras or a
Bailey's to have nuclear weapons?
What is the,
what is the point of which we are going
to put our foot down and say,
no,
we've gone far enough,
you know,
it's enough that 10 or so countries that
are acting responsibly so far have
nuclear weapons.
But that's enough where the world is
dangerous enough,
you know,
without a Astonia having a full up
nuclear delivery capability.
So,
but in any case,
we now have a case which I think is as
clear as can be that says we need to
stop this process here.
If America possesses armed forces for
any reason,
it is to protect the property and the
institutions and the lives of Americans
against threats like North Korea as a
nuclear armed North Korea,
I believe we ought to draw the line and
we ought to give a deadline by one
January next year.
Either the new,
the North Koreans are dismantling this
capability under international
inspection or we will help dismantle it.
It's funny you jumped the gun and went
right to my next question,
which was about nuclear nonproliferation
because I wanted to ask you,
is it specifically in North Korean
problem or is it a,
is it,
you mentioned believes,
right?
Okay.
Is it a beliefs problem?
So here's my question though.
This reminds me a little of like certain
naval treaties between the two world
wars where we're telling certain powers,
listen,
this is 70 plus year old technology,
the,
the basis for nuclear weapons,
right?
Um,
and,
and when you're telling other countries
that they can never develop that
capability,
isn't that the equivalent of locking
them into second power status
permanently in the way that the,
you know,
the Japanese had to have six battleships
to every 10 British battleships.
I mean,
is that,
uh,
it,
it seems to be the farther we get away
from,
from when that technology was invented,
the weirder it gets to tell people,
listen,
you can have anything.
But something that was invented darn
near 100 years ago is that she should
the foreign policy of the country be
that no nuclear powers that aren't
currently nuclear powers should be
allowed to become nuclear powers.
No,
the foreign policy of nuclear zero that
we would like to see a world without
nuclear weapons.
We would be much safer.
I mean our superiority and conventional
warfare is so pronounced that if nuclear
weapons disappeared everywhere in the
world,
it would improve the safety and security
of the American people.
And so our policy ought to be a zero
nuclear weapons for anybody.
Now,
how do we get there?
I have no idea because a country like
say Israel,
which commonly is understood to possess
an inventory of nuclear weapons is not
going to renounce them a given its
security situation,
you know,
and the geography lives.
So I don't know if a practical way to
get to zero.
I think it ought to be our objective and
I think we ought to work on it and try
to get there and eventually hopefully we
can get there.
But that ought to be our policy
objective.
And in the meantime,
we ought to say a yes,
nobody else can do it,
doesn't have them now is going to get
them and it's going to reduce them to
second class status and that's too bad
going to have to live with it.
But you know,
the world is increasingly dangerous.
The more people get that capability.
And uh,
so it does freeze people into a sort of
a formulaic,
a position like we tried to do with
capital ships at one time.
Remember though,
we,
this is not the first time we've,
we've outlawed chemical munitions,
right?
Sure.
Worldwide,
hopefully and now,
and we to enforced that a bit so we can,
uh,
put certain limitations that we hope are
universal on the kind of munitions that
are available for use in hostile,
uh,
engagements.
Okay.
About a conventional
situation then of,
of a,
of a change in power.
So you look at something like in Iran,
in their region,
uh,
all of us history not to know that,
that traditionally Iran or Persia is one
of the,
we'll call them the regional
superpowers.
Right?
And they wax and wane,
but sometimes they dominate the region.
Um,
it seems like the policy sometimes is
we're not going to let anyone change the
power relationships that are currently
in place.
Is that a viable,
it seems to be a hedge demonic power
sort of way of looking at it.
But is that a viable way to look at
something like the Middle East and say,
no,
you're not going to expand your,
um,
influence into Syria even if that's a
traditional Persian area of expansion?
Do you see where I'm going with this?
I mean,
how much can we,
uh,
we'll call it the United States is the
tip of the spear,
but we all represent a bunch of major
powers.
How much can we be the congress of
Vienna,
but constantly,
you know,
making sure that things stay stable,
we'll call them stable,
for lack of a better word.
So,
nuclear stability,
you're all for what about even like
regional power,
shifting stability?
We are no doubt a status quo power
because we're the top dog.
So we don't want that to change.
And hopefully I've never changes.
I mean,
if this country lasts a thousand years
and we all prayed,
well,
we,
we want to be at the top of the heap for
that whole period of time.
However,
you can't stand up the beaches edge and
an order that tied not to get your feet
wet,
you know,
so change is inevitable.
And uh,
what we have to do is to find a
constructive ways to allow change to
occur.
It doesn't threaten our position and
there's every reason by the way,
that we ought to be able to do that.
I mean,
uh,
certainly the tech technical change that
we see in the last,
uh,
couple of decades has been led by us.
We've created the instability onto the,
you know,
the technological front.
So it serves our purposes to be in the
vanguard of change where it's positive.
We just have to figure out where is it
positive negative.
Now,
in the case of Iran,
think it's been a long time since there
is the great,
it's a,
as a,
you know,
Syria recently,
it's certainly been the Ottoman Empire,
which not version Syria was a,
was a Ottoman province.
It was packed up by a
Yay
at the end of World War One.
And,
and by the way,
Lebanon was created separately.
I mean,
Syria considers Lebanon a Serbian
province,
Christian French enclave,
right?
So,
uh,
this,
the question you asked requires
sophistication in the answering.
It required sophistication in the
asking,
but uh,
so,
so statesmen are judged by their ability
to recognize what change is coming
anyway and running around and getting in
front of it.
Right?
That's how we define statesmanship and
cheap politicians are defined as people
who don't understand,
don't understand besides the depth I've
sat here and,
and mind you for wisdom on current
affairs and wisdom on the Vietnam War.
At no point did I ask you about the
drama though of flying hundreds of
missions into that situation and what I
would assume was a,
a more tense situation as,
as a anti air defenses got stronger and
stronger.
This is the understated question of all
time,
but can you describe to me just for a
second what the heck?
I mean,
when you look back on it,
I did things that were nothing like what
you did and I think,
God,
I was crazy.
And do you ever look back on that and
just think to yourself,
was that a different person or is it
like yesterday for you?
Do you miss it?
Combat is partly because of Hubris.
I mean,
I was arrogant.
Still am probably.
I mean,
my friends,
my friends say I was arrogant,
but when I did a strapped into an
airplane,
I don't think anybody can beat me.
So,
uh,
I never was a,
for me it wasn't a matter of bravery or
courage to go out there because I,
I knew I was going to kick the crap out
of the other guy rather than the
reverse.
So for me,
combat I food 285 combat region.
Uh,
I loved every,
every minute of it and I miss it.
I mean,
it's really,
really fun.
Uh,
and it's hard to explain.
I mean,
I am a professional warrior,
you know,
so that's,
that's what I was cut out to do and I
enjoyed it a lot.
And I'm going to recommend that people
read your books to get a really,
a more detailed version of everything we
were just talking about general.
Uh,
did I,
did I ask everything you would like to
talk about?
Is there anything that you'd like to
bring up that I left out?
No,
this has been a pretty wide ranging
conversation and more philosophical
then.
And uh,
I'm uh,
equipped to deal with you.
Ask Your questions or are too good.
I mean,
nobody had including your,
this,
uh,
you spoke to the Peloponnesian wars.
Nobody has the answers to these
questions and they're not,
it's not good to ask her professional,
a military guy.
You got to.
These are questions for the philosophy
professor.
Not For me,
but certainly it's been as wide ranging
as I could desire.
And,
and,
and more so than I'm pretty,
uh,
any good at handling
general,
you appreciate yourself.
I tailored those questions after
watching you talk.
And I think you're absolutely.
And you know what's funny is when I met
General Maddis,
I thought that's how he thought to.
You're very well versed in wide ranging
yourself.
Dan.
Thanks very much.
I enjoyed talking to you buddy.
My thanks to General Mcpeak for coming
on the program and putting up with my
traditionally unusual and long winded
questions.
His books are available everywhere.
We willing to.
Some of them on our website.
His latest,
as I said,
is roles and missions.
Cataloging his time as the 14th chief of
staff of the air force.
He's a fascinating guy.
I think you can agree and I appreciate
him coming on the program.
I am a true believer in the idea that
reading makes you a more formidable
version of you and it's hard to read
these days,
isn't it?
To find time to devote to simply looking
at a page for hours.
It's wonderful.
I love it,
but it's hard to do,
isn't it?
In this busy world,
a lot of people like to combine things
they have to do with things they'd like
to do.
Got to drive somewhere in traffic.
Why not make yourself a more formidable
version of you and enjoy a good book
while you're doing it?
Cause you got to keep your hands on the
wheel.
You got to keep your eyes on the road.
So let's make it an audio book and if
you're going to do that,
let's get it from audible.
The long running sponsors of this
program who helped make it possible for
you to educate yourself,
entertain yourself,
and read while you do something else.
It would be hard to find anyone who's
made it easier,
figured out more angles and things that
you would like as part of the process.
I mean,
you sign up for audible,
you get a free 30 day trial membership,
you'll get a free audio book.
You sign up for good.
They just keep coming and audibles
figured out a way to do this better than
anyone else.
I mean,
take for example,
they're whisper sync for voice aspect of
this whole thing where you can switch
back and forth between reading texts and
listening to the audio book across a
whole bunch of devices.
I mean you're reading on your kindle and
then you have to leave.
So you go into your car and you'll
listen in there.
You get out of your car,
your Amazon Echo,
place it right from where you left off.
That's pretty cool,
isn't it?
Don't miss a word.
You can share a book from your library
with anyone.
If it's their first time accepting a
book and they can listen to it for free
and you own your books.
This is key.
Me.
I don't want to buy something and then
not own it.
With audible.
You own the books that you purchase
through them now.
What books should you purchase?
Well,
of course,
whatever you think is going to make a
more formidable you,
but for me,
I am just addicted to reading the
accounts of participants in things like
the extremes of the human experience.
I mean,
take for example,
I'm Tony Mcphee,
who we just had on the four star general
love that stuff,
but at Vietnam is not your thing or
you're more of a land war person.
Well,
how about war as I knew it by General
George Patton,
probably the most famous,
arguably the most famous second world
war US general.
This book is a little different because
it is his remembrances and stuff out of
his diary,
but he died before the actual work that
he was going to put together,
came out,
but it's about as close as you can get.
The narrator even sounds a little patent
issue.
I mean,
if you want the definitive account that
exists from general George s dot
patents,
own written words,
go get wars.
I knew that if you're a military history
person,
it should be on your bookshelf anyway.
If you are a person who does a lot of
driving,
who can listen to books while they work,
well,
then maybe you need the audible version
to war as I knew it by General George
Patton.
Go pick that
up@audibleandgotoaudible.com
forward slash hardcore history and you
know,
basically virtually digitally.
Tell him I sent you.
You can also text all one word,
hardcore history to five,
zero,
zero dash five,
and get started with your free audio
book today.
The policy here is to let you hear the
shows and then decide for yourself what
they're worth.
We sort of rely on the honor system as
our business model and so far so good.
Thanks for all your support.
It keeps the lights on around here.
Go to Dan Carlin.com
for information on how to donate to the
show.